hello the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to as you all know I
love everything nostalgic but since day
one of starting this show everybody has
been requesting me to do a certain CGI
film that actually came out rather
recently a little film known as TMNT
I guess since I grew up with the other
Ninja Turtle movies everyone wants to
know what I think of this newest one and
since the Ninja Turtles were a large
part of my childhood I could technically
include this as something nostalgic now
I have not want to fall victim to peer
pressure I just do what everybody tells
me in the hopes of feeling less insecure
so I have decided to review the latest
installment of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle films is it ain't good is it as
strange or even as bad as some of the
others well let's take a look so it
starts off with our opening sequence
which apparently is so cheap they don't
even bother to spell out the entire
title we get a narrator played by the
anoints Fishburne who introduces us to
our heroes poor turtle genetically
reborn in the sewers of New York Wow
brief I mean
geesh they expect us to buy this whole
mutated turtle thing pretty quickly
don't they most people would consider
that a little out of the norm I mean is
the title the only real backstory we're
gonna get about him how the hell do you
think they describe the Star Wars
trilogy a guy a the sword his father
they don't get along this is like the
briefest description of the Ninja
Turtles ever imagine if you didn't know
who the Ninja Turtles were you'd swear
your high listening to this named after
the
Renaissance masters and trained as
ninjas but now a greater evil is poised
to destroy their very Brotherhood an
evil born 3,000 years ago yeah we
thought the turtle story was kind of
slow and a little lame so we decided to
make up another story enjoy that a
warrior king named yellow led a
brotherhood in his quest the warrior
learned of a constellation known as the
stars of kickin opening a portal to a
world of unknown power the pond the
portals opening 13 monsters were
released into our world are we still in
the same movie when did we suddenly
become 300 and you just glanced over the
turtles backstory what makes you think
we're gonna give a crap about this one
for Gondor
you know what I just realized this isn't
a movie this is an intro to a fucking
video game
the warrior king was left to eternally
walk the earth unable to die or forget
his horrible mistake
sensual America what is going on even
they show me the credits I swear Oh
still watching the trailers for five
different movies so okay we're in
Central America now I guess the perfect
setting for the Ninja Turtles why not as
we see an evil crime lord rules over the
good people of a local village he rides
off in his Jeep but is stopped by a tree
in the middle of the road
removing oh are you sure yourself
punch is also brave but the weak he's
coming it is the demon simply known as
Jojo did chunk oh dear no it turns out
it's a Teenage Mutant Ninja Jewpacabra
what's that evil criminal is place this
draws the attention of April O'Neil
voiced by Sarah Michelle Gellar gave up
her job as news reporter and now has the
popular occupation of Tomb Raider
Adventure Huntress I don't know her jobs
never actually explained
it's a long way from the city to just
drop in okay so they barely explained
the turtles backstory because apparently
they're making this film for the fans
who already know it the fans who know it
so well that they have to see the name
of the turtles under them so they can
tell which one is which that makes sense
whatever so Leah Niro explains to April
that he's in Central America because
it's Master Splinter's sent him there
why because he needs to find his inner
bullshit or something to lead the rest
of the Turtles properly and how are the
other Turtles you may ask well April
fills us in that Donatello is a customer
service rep for a computer company and
Michelangelo is a children's entertainer
the turtles have jobs well I mean I
guess I have to get the pizza somehow
but what were they stealing the money
before are the checks sent to the sewer
do they go to the bank do they apply
online with the hell am I talking about
turtles can't get jobs Raphael on the
other hand has turned into a reptile
without a cause as he continues to be
doing what the turtle should be doing
fighting crime
only he dresses up as a fearsome crime
fighter simply known as the night
watcher because I guess a giant
radioactive Green Monster wasn't
intimidating enough your training period
ended a year ago and splinter says you
don't write anymore
splitter sent me down here to become a
better leader I can't go back failure
besides these people need me more than
my brothers do did we miss some movie
somewhere I mean last time I checked
they went time-traveling or some shit
when did all this self-discovery
nonsense happen I don't know I just know
something
missing like the plot that brought us
here so we come back to New York where
we see the other terminals doing their
normal shit a skateboarding eating pizza
all that good stuff but Mikey seems to
miss the good old days I remember how
they used to feel busting up crime
syndicates sure they had a bunch of guns
but they weren't like these guns why do
you do this to yourself Mikey those
glory days are over forget about him
get on with your life concentrate on
your work yeah spoken like a true
has-been what am I missing
why are you fighting crime anymore
nobody's stopping you this isn't the
amphibian version of the watch Finch
just go go it would love to know what it
is that you do that's so great at least
we're contributing around here all you
do is sleep all day yeah I do nothing
you're right you got me all figured out
Wow remember when these guys used to be
fun those before every single comic book
hero I had to be brooding 24 hours a day
seriously lighten up first of all this
team you speak of doesn't exist anymore
its second of all excuse me I just
walked in from kung fu panda donut hello
his home has become like an empty shell
each of your brother's how can what did
they do this players voice it sounds
like mr. Miyagi if you smoked a million
marbles if you don't learn to recognize
this
pitiful so April returns home bringing a
statue to I guess her employer a man
named mr. winters both by Patrick
Stewart these statues may appear to be
only stone but they're like family to me
but it turns out he has sinister plans
as he's hired some rogue hitmen who may
sound familiar to you the Foot Clan and
I have come to hear your offer the Foot
Clan what they following the shredder
does your Cerritos lose this charity the
shredders sister or and how do we know
they're gonna explain anything here
don't owe explanation this backstory
anything okay you know what they're just
making up anything they want they don't
care what it connects to for all I know
Michelangelo is a dentist
Leonardo's an all-star and April's a
prostitute who cares I know let's see
how they box it up for so wrap while
continuing to play turtle and shiny
armor comes across an old friend
good old Casey Jones do you have him
fooled me Raph ah those me wasn't that
hard man you know you look like a big
metal turtle is that obvious huh
actually Tony Clark Kent is Superman so
they both sit and talk about how much it
sucks to be a superhero I don't even
care about Leo anymore I don't never
comes back come on aren't you being a
little hard on the guy I don't know
what's possible because it comes from
growing up with a houseful of brothers
I'm not trying to tell you what to do
I'm just saying that if it was my
brother I'd find a way to work it out
you know this isn't exactly what I had
in mind when I think of a Ninja Turtles
movie Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles giant
reptiles talking about things expressing
their emotions and analyzing them to in
next week when Donatello discovers that
he might have bipolar depression stay
tuned so we finally see Leonardo return
home and he reunite with his brothers
and sensei I have missed you Leonardo
missed you too father stop calling me
that I'm a fucking rat so now that Leo's
returned they finally decided to go
fight crime again it's about time but
Leonardo warns them that this is just a
training mission alright but remember
we're only up here for training you know
what I always say
trained by Dylan dude Mikey what have
you ever said I mean you're so
incredibly underdeveloped I forget what
your characteristics are well the first
training exercise is definitely a doozy
as a giant monster is seen attacking the
Foot Clan or being paid to bring it to
mr. winters you think we should help
these guys I'd rather enjoy the show
what do you say fearless leader I say we
stop talking we must get him back to
where the wild things are
so we partaken to be honest - pretty
cool actions but suddenly broken up when
mr. winters magically brings these stone
statues to life who look like the cast
of street fighter if they hate the
Transformers right so the catch of the
monster and leave the trolls behind in
fact they capture most of the monsters
as it seems that statues are the
brothers of mr. winters who it turns out
was the mortal world a long ago who has
to capture all 13 monsters so that when
the stars all realign he can send them
back to another dimension where do you
really give a shit at all I don't think
you do the original movies were pretty
basic stop the shredder the end do they
really think we're gonna follow this
cramp about dimensions and interstellar
dog piss I really doubt that doesn't
prove anything
so rappin Casey find another monster
being attacked as they tried to
intervene but they themselves are
attacked as they hide in a shack on one
of the roofs
I got ahead of your f you sure know how
to show a lady a good time is there
something you'd like to tell us Casey no
Raphael thinks they should attack while
Leonardo says they should check what
splinter first Brad finally gets fed up
with Leo and decides to go solo yeah I'm
so glad Leo left for that year in
training he's truly molded his family
into a powerhouse of teamwork heaven II
whatever
so riff tries to find what's left of the
monsters and comes across the noise of
autocrat baby as Siemens Chihuahua skate
ramp is confronted by Leo actually can't
put it together but he's the night
watcher even though it was apparently
obvious in an earlier scene so I'm gonna
give you one chance to just walk away
and stop this vigilante nonsense yes
stop this vigilante nonsense and be like
us the non nonsense of vigilantism so
they have a little fight scene when Leo
max grabs helmet on revealing his true
identity laughs what well you know
what's wondering how many crime
fighter's only have three fingers but
still I'm very shocked so Leo continues
to lecture as Raph has none of Leo's
self righteous bullcrap and neither do
we for that matter this qualifies is
just fine
dressing up like it's Halloween every
night risking the safety of our family
yes that is what you were supposed to do
I think is actually the definition of
superhero but Leo Stan's body is not
being superhero isn't as it looks like
the two are ready to fight over their
points of view don't do this rap
I'm done taking orders I could really
care less about what's going on I mean
we don't really know why they hate each
other nothing about their anger makes
sense
Leo's logic is crazy rant anger is just
pointless why am I supposed to be
invested someone's crank but leo is
kidnapped by the evil statue gang has
taken back to be presented as one of the
13 monsters Raph goes home to tell
splinter the bad news I know why you
chose him now I know that there's a
reason why he's the better son and I'm
not you may not be my favorite student
it does not mean that you are my least
favorite son the important thing is that
you failed at something but Master
Splinter
I missed a big tonight they took him
hey what this is why you're my least
favorite son what a disappointment so
the bad guys lock up Leo with the other
monsters as the rest of the gang gets
ready for the rescue including April
Casey and even splinter so our heroes
get together and infiltrate the evil
okay this is officially a video game
just pop out the controllers and we'll
play the rest
oh wow
Oh check it out that would be the
swirling vortex oh I hate me
come on seas I wish I had Chico so you
can skip so they finally owe a lot of
the cages and break him out here rapidly
I'll finally get a chance to reconcile
you're gonna need these if you're gonna
lead us out of here I'm gonna need you
to
kissing you fool there will never be a
better time huh turtle sex will have to
wait as it turns out mr. winters has
been kicked out of his own team why
because it turns out he wants to send
the monsters home not bring more into
this world see he's actually a good guy
which leads us with these stoners as the
villains brothers we are no breakfast
for you with one monster still free the
curse will never be prepared especially
love this scene where the statues offer
the Foot Clan a chance to work with them
and rule the world
join us Foot Clan swear your allegiance
to us and no harm will befall do ok the
food ninja is not without honor
we work for winters not you ah I thought
we worked for money yeah me too screw
honor if we can rule the world
ok we're gone so April the Foot Clan go
to find the 13th monster as the bad guys
just let him go for some reason we'll
get about them by the time they return
the portal will already be closed
I suppose I'm kind of stupid that way
but at least I know my cockiness won't
in any way lead to my downfall so the
turtles stay behind to fight April on
the Foot Clan find the monster and try
to lead it back to the building where
were these monsters all the time anyway
were they in the city the whole time
that'd be pretty hard to miss maybe they
travel to the city good god key imagine
I'll operate that trick must have been
well be the way the monster is brought
back and knocked into the portal as the
evil cosplay statues are destroyed
forever
so now that that's taken care of what
about the foot clans I mean are they
still enemies or what savor your victory
tonight for soon we will have further
business together the kind that involves
familiar faces from your past I'm
talking about sequels big plots that we
haven't really come up with yet type
sequels now you're smoking your eyes so
with that weak trailer for the next film
established we also see what happens to
mr. winters who is no longer immortal
no I want to see how stupid this gets so
he evaporates into golden sand no reason
why or any logical understanding he's
just sand maybe he was a pixie dust
junkie and just exploded onto many happy
thoughts so the turtles go home and
winter is helmet to their trophy
collection and go into the night to
fight crime once again so what if we
learned from this epic tale of adventure
I have absolutely no idea I mean what
did we learn on his trip I don't know
how's the team any stronger than it was
before I don't know is the message that
vigilantism is bad because it looks like
they're going right back to doing it
again at the end anyway so really what
have we learned we've won the way a
franchise instead its Reichstag hot egg
dad okay okay so how does TMNT fare out
well to be honest it's not horrible it's
not a really bad bad it's just not very
engaging I mean the story is just all
over the place and the characters aren't
really that developed I mean I know they
set them up in the show in the movies
but those are two different entities as
well as a long long time ago I guess
maybe this is supposed to be a spin-off
of the new show that's come out but I
never watched it
anyone who has and it's going to be
totally lost that is if it is a spin-off
I really don't know
but I'm looking at this though the CGI
does kick ass especially the design of
the city I mean the angles the lighting
the shadows this is a very cool-looking
movie but I don't think that's enough to
really save it it's vague it's confusing
and it's just a mess much like my sex
life there I mean do I say that out loud
hey and that's why I'm the greatest
lover ever and don't you forget I lend a
statue critic I remember so you don't
have to
hello I'm that guy with the glasses and
there are many questions that I'm sure
you want to ask me like what am i doing
at the end of this video are you
actually that handsome in real life and
why did the Nostalgia Critic wear
mascara this last video anyway well none
of those questions are important next to
the greatest question of them all how do
I get geek vine cards that's right it's
a fucking commercial I bet you thought I
was going to say something meaningful
like I usually do but it turns out I'm
an unbelievable whore and how can you
not be when you were actually featured
on the cards look at that ask that guy
with the glasses has this very own card
isn't it beautiful yes there are also
other characters you can get though like
the nostalgia critic Chester a bum and
even hamster jelly has a card
how did hamster jelly get a card you
don't want to know
they're only seven dollars is that
fantastic now that we have that out of
the way we can get back to answering the
important questions like why did the
Nostalgia Critic wear eyeliner in his
last review anyway it was from the
Melbourne sketch all right I don't wear
eyeliner he's lying of course it's
because he's an Evo nice he is this is
that guy with the glasses saying buy
these cars today or I'll come to your
house sodomized and kill you